foreign
[Music]
I need you we're gonna destroy their
whole nuclear program
we know the risk trust me
please be safe will you okay
oh my God
my soul just came through the cia's
targeting Iranian nuclear facilities
we leave for 15 minutes
stretching point
[Music]
to go home and I'll be with you
the distance is not the main issue
that's what's in between
any of them catch my guy I'll sell them
to the highest bidder there will be no
Sanctuary for you
raise your hands
do it before they get Trigger Happy
[Music]
me
tell me what's truly going on we cut
outs in an even bigger game this is my
life in your hands
no one is coming to rescue us
sorry
get down
[Music]
thank you